et nos clients et donc nous sommes en
rien responsables aujourd'hui bien au
contraire nous voulons aider le
gouvernement tout en restant ouvert et
donc notre métier vous la difficulté
vous savez si l'équilibré car il faut
entre protéger les citoyens et nous
préserver les entreprises
voilà il va il faut bien trouver des
réponses en peut plus fermer des
entreprises
on peut plus fermer des entreprises
qu'est ce que demandent nos cafetiers
restaurateurs et hôteliers c'est simple
ils veulent travailler alors derrière
bien sûr il ya des mesures
d'accompagnement qui sont très
importantes
mais le premier point qu'ils veulent
c'est travailler donc est trouvé dans
liberty comprennent pas qu'on les a
montrés du doigt comme ça sur des sujets
comme ça hein cafetiers et restaurateurs
ne décolère pas donc face aux nouvelles
mesures restrictives entre ceux qui ont
dû fermer boutique et ceux qui doivent
baisser le rideau plutôt l inquiétude
grandit tout comme le cas de
contamination et pour parler de la
situation de ces professionnels nous
allons retrouver nos deux invités et
nous sommes avec olivier marc et aux
restaurateurs patron du bistrot mais
zing à paris bonsoir bonsoir avec vous
christian saint-etienne économistes de
bonsoir
alors la colère des restaurateurs
christian saint-etienne ne retombe pas
parmi d'autres est ce que ce sont les
sacrifiés du coc vie d'aujourd'hui
christian saint-etienne le gouvernement
comme vous le savez depuis mars n'a pas
véritablement bien géré cette crise
actuellement donc il ya un petit rebond
de l'activité du coc vide
je pense que le gouvernement est en mode
panique dans la mesure où on a laissé
pendant l'été un beau coup de deux
groupes se retrouver en famille ou dans
les boîtes de nuit ou dans les bars et
que même si les jeunes ne sont pas
malades ils ont été un gros recteur de
deux déplacements de la maladie est
aujourd'hui le gouvernement étant en
panique il décide de prendre des mesures
drastiques mais sans mesurer les
conséquences je pense que ça va être
l'objet du débat
je termine ma réponse en vous disant
qu'en fait le gouvernement
outre la mauvaise gestion de la pandémie
par eux-mêmes a énormément de
difficultés à être capable de balancer
les risques entre crise économique et
crise épidémique est ce qu'ils ne
mesurent pas la mauvaise façon dont on a
géré cette crise au printemps nous a
déjà coûté 750 mille emplois si on
devait avoir un nouveau plantage en
septembre octobre novembre ça pourrait
nous coûter un demi million d'emplois
supplémentaires et je le termine en
disant que sur un million et demi de 1
million 250 mille un million et demi de
chômeurs de plus on peut avoir des
dizaines de milliers peut-être même des
centaines de milliers de faillite ce qui
peut provoquer beaucoup de concerts de
suicides et de dépressions donc
contrebalancer le risque économique et
le risque épidémique
ce n'est pas aussi simple il faut aussi
prendre en compte qu'une faillite
économique entraîne des conséquences
médicales colossal alors olivier marleix
tournant tomber à l'instant de christian
saint-etienne nous dire voilà cet été
bien il ya eu des rassemblements de
jeunes aujourd'hui on en paye les
conséquences notamment dans les bars ou
encore les restaurants
est ce que finalement les mesures aient
été suffisamment drastiques pour
aujourd'hui être obligé finalement de
fermer ces mêmes lieux de barrez
restants
aujourd'hui on a l'impression nous
d'être un peu les marqueurs de l'action
politique du gouvernement
les précédents aujourd'hui depuis le
début de la crise je pense que tous les
patrons de bar resto bistro responsables
ont pris des dispositions suivez les
consignes on fait en sorte que une
distanciation qui existent que les gens
portent leurs masques à l'intérieur des
établissements on a tout fait pour
après comme dans toutes les professions
il peut y avoir quelques cas où ce nom
n'a pas été respecté mais est ce que
pour quelques cas qui ne respectent pas
et l'état n'avait qu'à les sanctionner
doit-on pénaliser toute une profession
c'est une vraie question qu'on se pose
aujourd'hui parce que aujourd'hui nous
comme tout chef d'entreprise on a besoin
de visibilité
grosso modo depuis mars nous n'avons
aucune visibilité sur notre avenir doit
faire comment le faire aujourd'hui on en
train de précariser des emplois c'est
une période où la rentrée on prend des
étudiants qui viennent faire des
contrats de 20 heures aujourd'hui on ne
les prend pas comment vont ils faire
pour payer leur loyer etc
c'est un vrai souci par rapport à ça et
nous on se demande comment vont vivre
nos entreprises demain alors justement
olivier marzotto je me tourne vers vous
christian saint-etienne l'exécutif a
fait des annonces deux annonces
principal pour atténuer la fronde
prolongement du chômage partiel à 100%
jusqu'au 31 décembre et plafonds de
solidarité désormais fixé à dix mille
euros contre 1500 euros jusque là
christian saint-etienne est ce qu'on
peut sauver les meubles avec ces mesures
on peut sauver les meubles si l affaire
nature est extrêmement limitée dans le
temps
on a réduit la période de confinement
pour les individus deux semaines à une
semaine je pense que là si on annonçait
que la fermeture des bars étaient
limités à deux semaines avec une
indemnisation complète
ça permettrait de limiter la fronde
parce que vous avez raison il ya un
risque d' extrême dérapage sur le plan
politique c'est à dire qu'à un moment
donné le gouvernement peut prendre peut
perdre de compte
le politique de la situation donc je
pense que le gouvernement intérêt à dire
on ferme de semaine les bars je ne
personnellement je ne vois pas pourquoi
on ferme les resteront parce que si on
applique de manière extrêmement strictes
les mesures barrières dans les
restaurants normalement les gens sont
protégées au moins autant que dans les
transports publics dans un restaurant où
on a un mètre entre les tables vous êtes
autant protégé que quand vous êtes dans
le métro je prends sans arrêt et on en
est à touche touche donc pour les bars
peut-être deux semaines max né les
restaurants je pense que il faut faire
une analyse extrêmement précises je suis
d'accord avec l'autre personne sur le
fait que le gouvernement doit être
beaucoup plus strict avec ceux qui ne
respectent pas les mesures barrières
donc si on a des restaurateurs qui
s'engagent à respecter très strictement
des mesures barrières je pense qu'il
faut leur laisser leur chance pour les
bars c'est plus compliqué mais pour les
restaurants je pense qu'il faut les
laisser ouverts
olivier marzotto donc ses principales
dispositions pour atténuer la fronde du
gouvernement tout à l'heure vous nous
disiez on n'a pas de visibilité avec ces
nouvelles dispositions
toujours pas de visibilité non plus
selon vous qui n'ont pas de visibilité
on ne sait pas quelle échéance
on est bon on sait pas qui va fermer qui
ne va pas fermer est-ce qu'on va fermer
est-ce qu'on reste comme ça est ce que
c'est les bars jusqu'à 22h les
restaurants déjà c'était pas très claire
leur mesure
qu'est ce qu'ils appellent un restaurant
aujourd'hui est-ce que hambach qui sert
des planches et où les gens mangent
est-ce que ça reste en fait dans tout ça
il n'y a aucune clarté il ya un vrai
manque de clarté sur la communication et
il ya un autre point qui est quand même
essentiel c'est que aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas de quoi va être fait demain
mais véritablement pour nous 1500 à
10000 euros est ce qu'on perd 50 60 70 %
du chiffre d'affaires moi j'ai eu une
entreprise j'ai dix salariés ils sont
tous inquiets ils se demandent comment
va payer les salaires ils se demandent
de quoi va être fait demain et
et comme tout chef d'entreprise je pense
qu'on est le seul secteur où on nous dit
vous ouvrez vous fermez vous allez droit
de faire ceci vous aidera à faire cela
il n'y a pas un autre secteur où ça sera
accepté est donc c'est très compliqué
très compliqué christian saint-etienne
est ce qu'on peut d'ores et déjà estimer
un certain nombre finalement
d'établissement qui ne pourront pas
rouvrir à l'issue de toutes ces mesures
et de ces fermetures
déjà en une première estimation sous
réserve de confirmation un tiers des
flux des fleuristes définitivement fermé
s'il y a vous prenez les restaurateurs
la crise du printemps si l'on rajoute
des fermetures maintenant on pourrait
avoir 15 à 20 % des restaurateurs qui
n'aurait au bois pas je pense qu'olivier
marzotto a dit quelque chose d'important
par rapport à ce qui s'est passé à
marseille
je pense que dans ce contexte il est
impératif notamment pour la région
parisienne qui est non seulement le
moteur économique de la france et on
sait peu que 30 % du pipe de la france
est fait en ile-de-france et en plus
c'est la moitié des recettes
touristiques de france
donc pour l'île de france je pense qu'il
est impératif que le gouvernement ouvre
une concertation avec les professionnels
olivier mareuse eto'o disais à l'instant
un restaurant ok si tout le monde est
assis à une table mais si on sert des
planches comment ça fonctionne
donc il faut ouvrir une concertation
avec des règles extrêmement précises qui
permettent aux restaurateurs de
s'adapter si on considère qu
effectivement pour les bars c'est plus
compliqué même pour les bars il faut
donner une période très précises par
exemple dire on ferme les bars de
semaine on laisse les restaurants
ouverts mais avec des mesures
extrêmement précise et une concertation
qui permettent d'avoir des règles qui
sont claires pour tous les restaurateurs
voilà il faut un cadre précis et des
durée précise sinon les gens vont péter
les plombs parce que c'est leur vie
c'est tout ce qu'ils ont construit
pendant une vie qui se joue alors
justement les gens vont péter les plombs
là qu'on l'entend à la colère des des
restaurateurs des gérants de bars un
appel à une action de brassards noirs
d'ailleurs été lancé pour le vendredi 2
octobre à 11h45
c'est par le chef le chef philippe
etchebest
est-ce que vous alliez il participe et
olivier marais tôt oui bien sûr tout ce
qui aujourd'hui peut faire porter la
voix des restaurateurs et notre
profession est important je pense qu'il
ya un point qui là aussi très important
c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans la
communication du gouvernement
il n'y a aucun chiffre concret sur les
cas qui sont sortis à cause des bistrots
on a vraiment on a vraiment l'impression
d'être le marqueur de l'action politique
et que aujourd'hui si les explications
du gouvernement sur les cas issus de
notre profession était chiffré clair
précis il n'aurait pas cette fronde
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que dès
qu'ils veulent faire quelque chose à un
moment ils vont dire on ferme quelque
chose à ebb enfermé bistrot on ferme les
yeux les luttes convivialité mais la
grande erreur nous on est client les a
tous les jours ah c'est que aujourd'hui
un des principaux endroits de kloster
c'est les réunions familiales ou les
réunions amicales dans les appartements
il faut pas croire que si on ferme les
gens vont arrêter de vivre
ils vont se retrouver dans des
appartements sans aucune marier sans
aucune barrière sans aucun gestes
barrières sans protection etc
et je pense qu'on assistera à la
continuité d'une progression du cac au
vide voilà christian saint-etienne est
ce que vous vous rejoignez ce constat
d'olivier ma rhéto qui pointe un manque
de clarté du gouvernement dans ses
échanges avec les restaurateurs les
barmans il ya deux points de ce que
vient de dire olivier marais tôt sur
lequel je rejoins le premier c'est le
manque de concertation je les ai évoqué
précédemment
donc c'est extrêmement important qui est
des règles qui soient concertées avec
les professionnels met le deuxième point
sur lequel je le rejoins j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire dans des
interviews
c'est effectivement la sphère
personnelle les allemands viennent
d'annoncer que selon les régions
département par département en allemagne
par lander ou par ville
il va y avoir des limites aux réunions
de la sphère personnelle c'est à dire
que ça n'a pas de sens de faire
les bars et des restaurants si on permet
aux gens de s'assembler à 50 ou à 100
dans des résidences dans des maisons de
campagne ou dans des salles de fête donc
dans la concertation qu'il faut ouvrir
avec les bars restaurants
il faut inclure la réflexion sur ce que
vont déjà lancé les allemands c'est à
dire les limites à mettre sur la sphère
personnelle
il faut une cohérence entre ce qui est
fait du côté des bars restaurants et ce
qu'on fait sur la sphère personnelle
sinon c'est incompréhensible dans tout
le monde alors olivier marzotto dans ce
contexte on voit le nombre de cas de
contamination qui augmente le nombre de
décès également qu'est ce que vous
proposez vous très concrètement
aujourd'hui au gouvernement
nous ce qu'on propose c'est déjà qu'il
fallait appliquer les mesures qu'ils ont
prises
je pense que notre profession si elle
applique un protocole qui a été négocié
avec le gouvernement peut pas l'oublier
c'est pas nous qui avons inventé le
protocole qui aujourd'hui est en place
dans les bars restaurants si on met déjà
les moyens pour faire appliquer les
sanctionner les contrevenants à ce
protocole on pourra continuer à faire
vivre nos entreprises sauvegarder les
emplois à créer une continuité dans la
convivialité aussi parce que les gens
ont besoin de ça dans cette période
extrêmement tendu tout le monde tout le
monde a besoin de ça et on pourra tous
vivre ensemble en faisant attention à ne
pas propager ce second vide
christian saint-etienne pour conclure
alors au delà de la conséquence directe
sur les propriétaires et et personnels
de bars et restaurants est ce que ces
fermetures ont un impact économique sur
d'autres secteurs
oui j'y pensais à l'instant on veut il
faut que l'économie fonctionne sinon on
va creuser collectivement on vient de
voir que le confinement du printemps
nous a coûté 750 mille emplois et 200
milliards de dette publique en plus on a
une dette publique qui va être la fin de
l'année à 118 points de pub alors comme
dans ce quasiment le double de ce qui
est permis dans le traité de maastricht
et les règles européennes c'est à dire
60 points de pipe
vous avez des restaurateurs qui après la
claque du printemps ont pris dans leurs
économies pour relancer leurs activités
si on leur balance une baffe à l'automne
je pense qu'on va perdre tout un secteur
d'activité qui est clé à la fois pour le
tourisme parce que les touristes qui
viennent à paris ou dans d'autres
régions france ils viennent aussi pour
la convivialité qu'on trouve dans les
bars et les restaurants donc si vous
avez tout un segment de l'offre qui
disparaissent a réduit l'attractivité en
termes de tourisme
mais l'autre aspect c'est qu'on veut que
l'économie continue de fonctionner donc
il faut que les gens des jeunes
un midi c'est pour ça que tout à l'heure
je parle sous contrôle dès la profession
des bars restaurants mais je fais une
distinction entre bars et restaurants
pour moi c'est presque un service public
les restaurants 1 le restaurant
notamment hnidy pour que les gens
travaillent donc si on ferme les
restaurants ça envoie un signal
extrêmement négatif et est même avec un
risque sanitaire supplémentaire parce
que si les gens ne peuvent pas manger
dans des restaurants dans lesquels on
appliquera strictement les règles
barrière qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
ils vont se faire des boîtes pour
déjeuner ils vont aller manger des
sandwichs et ils vont le manger au
bureau ils vont aller le manger dans des
salles de dans l'entreprise où il ya un
bar il va être collés les uns aux autres
donc en terme de règles barrière c'est
pire que d'aller au restaurant donc
c'est pour ça qu'il faut que le
gouvernement pense à 3 à 3 simultanément
à trois éléments
bien sûr la survie du secteur des
départs un restaurant mais c'est
également comme je les ai dit tout à
l'heure il faut qu'il y ait une
cohérence entre les règles imposées ce
secteur et ce qu'on fait dans la sphère
privée
on peut pas on peut pas dire enfermés
par restaurant et on laisse les gens se
réunira 200 dans une salle des fêtes
antique j'ai pris goût et troisième
élément nouveau conclut hans
conséquences d'une fermeture des
restaurants parce que d'une certaine
façon c'est un service public
si on veut que l'économie continue en a
besoin que les travailleurs puissent se
restaurer merci à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté notre invitation merci à vous
olivier marais tôt je rappelle que vous
êtes restaurateur à patron du bistrot
mais zynga paris merci avoue christian
saint-etienne je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste
et puis outre ce rendez vous avec les
professionnels de la restauration le
gouvernement a dévoilé tout à l'heure le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale le déficit de la sécu
qui sera de près de 45 milliards d'euros
pour l'année en cours un budget très
attendue par le corps médical
ils réclament depuis plusieurs mois une
hausse des moyens alloués au secteur ce
matin le ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand s'est engagé à mettre en place
dès 2021 les premières décisions du c ur
de la santé a lié à l'augmentation
salariale du personnel hospitalier
au travers de ce plfss ce sont donc bien
8,2 milliards d'euros qui viendront
reconnaître l'engagement de celles et
ceux qui font notre système de santé
cette déroute 6 milliards d'euros pour
les personnels paramédicaux dans les
établissements de santé et dans les
ehpad publics et privés
c'est une hausse je le rappelle de 183
euros nets par mois pour tous les
personnels non médicaux complété par 35
euros net par mois en moyenne de
rémunération supplémentaire pour les
personnels qui sont au contact des
patients voyez qu'on est déjà à plus de
220 euros une prime d'engagement
collectif qui peut concerner tous les
membres des équipes et qui peut
atteindre 100 euros net de plus par mois
ce qui fait qu'on peut être déjà
potentiellement au delà de 300 euros net
par mois auxquels on peut encore ajouter
d'autres dispositions comme la
majoration des heures supplémentaires
50% en france toujours avec ce rapport à
charge de 56 pages publiée aujourd'hui
par amnesty international law and g
pointe l'arsenal juridique déployé dans
l'hexagone pour réprimer les
mobilisations comme celle des gilets
jaunes ou encore celle contre la réforme
des retraites avec des dizaines de cas
de manifestants pacifiques je cite
arrêtés arbitrairement et victime
d'acharnement judiciaire
amnesty international réclame un cadre
juridique plus protecteur pour la
liberté de manifester pour commenter ce
rapport au vitriol
nous sommes avec alexis poulain c'est
notre rubrique qu'elle l'ait dit
tous alexis poulain bonsoir merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
que dit précisément cette nouvelle
enquête bien cette nouvelle enquête elle
montre qu'au delà des violences
policières qui il ya pu avoir durant les
manifestations il y avait aussi une
certaine violence juridique d'une
certaine façon avec des lois contraires
au droit international des lois
françaises d'exception qui ont permis
par exemple entre novembre 2018 et
juillet 2019 de mettre plus de onze
mille deux cent trois personnes en garde
à vue dont 5962 ont pu être libéré sans
poursuites vous dire combien de garde à
vue et bien n'avait pas lieu d'être
autre chose il y à ce délit d' outrage à
agent outrage à agents de la fonction
publique qui peut être soit par des mots
des gestes ou bien par des écrits par
exemple vous avez une enquête vous
outrage ouverte à narbonne en mai 2010
neuf parce qu'il y avait une banderole
tenue par des manifestants qui disaient
simplement en mai oui au muguet non lbd
donc c'est vous dire là aussi un peu
l'ampleur de ce dispositif pour très peu
de choses et rien qu'en 2019
il n'y a plus il ya plus de vingt mille
personnes reconnues coupables d' outrage
ensuite il y a eu ses loi sur les
manifestations non autorisées vous
rappeler lors des actes d gilet jaune
quasiment toutes les rues de la capitale
étaient interdites à la manifestation
certains leaders un défilé jaune n'avait
pas le droit d'arriver dans les
quartiers autour des champs elysées ou
des lieux de pouvoir eh bien rien que
pour ces contraventions pour
manifestation non autorisée
c'est plus de 1000 contraventions à
partir de mars 2019
et puis il y a pire encore c'est ces
lois qui ressemble minority report où on
arrête quelqu'un pour ce qu'il pourrait
faire dans le futur c'est à dire
participation à un groupement en vue de
préparation de violences et là se sont
fait arrêter de nombreuses personnes
plusieurs milliers là encore simplement
parce qu'il portait des lunettes de
protection ou bien des masques contrôler
les gaz lacrymogènes
certains mêmes qui ont été arrêtés dans
le cadre de ces attroupements en vue de
commettre des violences étaient
journalistes
et là on est vraiment dans quelque chose
de graves parce que on est au delà du
cadre du droit et on est en train
d'attaquer le droit de manifester c'est
ce que dénonce amnesty international
alexis le covin at il renforcé les lois
d'exception
alors oui d'une certaine façon on le
voit et vous en parliez à l'instant avec
toutes ces mesures de fermeture des
restaurants des bars sans trop savoir si
on a le droit encore devoir de l'alcool
en mangeant ou pas où la police ne sait
plus exactement que faire pour mettre
des contraventions
il ya eu les autorisations de sortie
lors du confinement
il ya eu beaucoup de choses aujourd'hui
bien sûr les manifestations publiques
qui sont réduites à moins de 1000
personnes moins de 10 personnes sur la
voie publique donc tout est fait pour
empêcher les gens bien sûr de se
regrouper
là c'est pour la protection sanitaire
pour éviter que le virus se diffuse mais
ce qui est drôle c'est que vous aviez
des lois comme par exemple celle d'avril
2010 9 qui interdisait de se couvrir le
visage est bien celle là n'a plus lieu
d'être puisque aujourd'hui le masque est
obligatoire
donc là le gouvernement ne sais même
plus comment gérer et malgré les lois
liberticides ducobu des biens ils sont
obligés d'admettre qu'on doit se couvrir
le visage et c'est pour notre bien cette
fois ci
et pour conclure cette interrogation
emmanuel macron se posent en défenseurs
des libertés et des démocraties
européennes est ce que vous y voyez un
paradoxe
oui c'est assez paradoxal parce qu'à
l'international emmanuel macron et
président de la france ce pays de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen qui est un peu le far des
libertés à l'international et la petit à
petit et bien les différents pays voisin
où beaucoup plus loin ont vu comment ce
pays d'une autre la france gérait les
manifestations gérer le droit de
manifester ou simplement les libertés
fondamentales et on peut être inquiet et
c'est ce que dit d'ailleurs amnesty
international parce qu'il est là des
lois d'exception qui vont à l'encontre
du droit international
or la france n'a pas lieu d'être et
pourtant emmanuel macron bien parade sur
la scène internationale du liban à la
lituanie en passant par le mali pour
défendre les démocraties européennes
pour défendre les droits et les libertés
fondamentales qui sont le projet soit
disant de cette construction européenne
on peut se poser la question quand il
montre du doigt viktor orban
par exemple pour des mesures
contradictoires et contraignantes pour
la presse
ce qu'il en est ici en france puisqu'on
a vu les journalistes empêchés de faire
leur travail
entravés par les policiers qui
demandaient la carte de presse ils n'en
n'ont aucun droit
et puis bien toutes ces lois dénoncée
par amnesty international qui sont loin
loin de l'idéal français de liberté
égalité fraternité
merci beaucoup avec six poulains je
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialistes et
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur la rencontre à vilnius entre
emmanuel macron et la chef de
l'opposition biélorusse svetlana tirano
sky à vladimir poutine lui dénonce des
pressions extérieures sans précédent sur
la biélorussie et puis nous évoquerons
la réunion d'urgence du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu sur le conflit entre
l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
oui
il
je
[Musique]
nous
est ce la musique en france
[Musique]
hu
et
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française à svetlana tirano sky à
s'exprimera devant les députés français
le 7 octobre l'annoncé a été faite tout
à l'heure par l'opposante biélorusse
après sa rencontre avec emmanuel macron
à vilnius elle assure avoir le soutien
du président français en visite en ce
début de semaine dans les états baltes
allez précision tout de suite à moscou
de notre correspondant antoine cléroux
le président français l'opposante
biélorusses se sont rencontrés pour ce
qui a été d'après cette dernière un
dialogue franc et honnête
afin de trouver une issue à l'élection
présidentielle controversée du 9 août
dernier
emmanuel macron ainsi proposé à son
interlocutrice la médiation de la france
et de l'europe notamment via l'eau et
ses suites la nature and of gaia se
réjouit pour sa part d'avoir reçu le
soutien du président français
le président français a promis de tout
faire pour nous aider à négocier et à
trouver des solutions dans la crise
biélorusse il nous assure son soutien et
cela est très important pour nous tous
nous avons reçu une invitation à prendre
la parole devant le parlement français
et nous l'avons accepté
l'opposante biélorusse réfugiés en
lituanie et espère aussi voir emmanuel
macron user de ses bonnes relations avec
vladimir poutine pour obtenir une
transition pacifique en biélorussie le
président russe s'est également une fois
de plus exprimé sur le dossier
biélorusse en rappelant les liens qui
unissent les deux pays mais aussi les
tentatives de pression extérieure de ces
dernières semaines il est actuellement
compte tenu de la situation difficile
dans laquelle s'est retrouvée la
biélorussie notamment à cause de
pressions extérieures sans précédent
après l'élection présidentielle
je tiens à répéter que les relations
entre la russie et la biélorussie
résiste au passage du temps et aux
circonstances changeantes et repose sur
des bases solides car nos états sont
liés par d'étroites relations
culturelles et spirituelles enracinée
dans la durée
ainsi que par des relations familiales
et parental et une histoire commune
emmanuel macron on est bien conscient et
soutient ostensiblement l'opposante
biélorusse comme on vient de le voir
mais il connaît tout le poids de moscou
dans cette affaire d'ailleurs il a dit
lui même au début de sa tournée dans les
pays baltes la russie est un
interlocuteur incontournable et avant de
se rendre à riga en lettonie emmanuel
macron s'est exprimé au côté de son
homologue lituanien au centre de son
discours la crise politique en
biélorussie ne le président français
réitère sa conviction d'un nécessaire
dialogue avec la russie sans qui une
aide durable en europe ne serait pas
possible
notre vision des choses est que si nous
voulons construire la paix durablement
sur le continent européen
il nous faut travailler avec la russie
car nous partageons une histoire et une
géographie et nous partageons parfois
cette histoire pour le pire et je le dis
sur un sol qui a vécu ce pire qui a vécu
l'oppression qui a vécu les morts mais
nous ne pouvons pas faire comme si
l'europe était une île loin de la russie
est par ailleurs le royaume uni et le
canada ont annoncé les sanctions visant
lui responsables biélorusses dont le
président alexandre loukachenko
londres et ottawa dénoncent la gestion
jugée répressive du mouvement de
contestation à minsk
et pour revenir sur les dernières prises
de parole des présidents français et
russe sur la situation en biélorussie
nous sommes avec karine bechet golovkov
professeur invité à l'université d'état
de moscou karine bechet golovkov merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors emmanuel macron a donc affiché sa
proximité avec oew et la nature and of
sky à elle a été invitée à un renvoi
rencontre et on le disait le 7 octobre
les députés français alors pourquoi la
france selon vous semble s'y activent
dans le dossier biélorusse cela la
france est active dans dossier villes
russes parce qu'il faut bien que
quelqu'un fin ce travail sur le devant
de la scène
si l'on en croit les résultats dit
hadi renseignement extérieur russe cela
fait des années que la cia et le
département d'état travaille la société
civile biélorusse financer couple skull
d'opposition qui sont formés en géorgie
en ukraine en pologne et dans les pays
baltes mais il est évident que sur ce
dossier les etats unis ne peuvent pas
agir directement donc il faut des
personnages parlant pour jouer ce rôle
manifestement macro on se sent
parfaitement à l'aise dans le rôle donc
il tient le devant de la scène
c'est ce que l'on appelle normalement de
l'ingérence alors justement de son côté
le président russe un parle de pressions
extérieures son précédent tout en
rappelant la longue histoire on l'a
entendu unissant les deux pays
alors en quoi ce paramètre est important
à prendre en compte dans la gestion du 2
du dossier biélorusse la biélorussie et
la russie sont deux pays frères qui ont
une histoire millénaire comme henin cela
fait quelques années qu'ils sont séparés
par les aléas l'histoire et la chute de
l'urss
sinon ça fait quand même millénaire que
c'est le même peuple donc à toucher la
biélorussie c'est aussi touché la russie
comme l'ukraine était un des peuples
frères de la russie historiquement
maintenant c'est le tour de la
biélorussie nous sommes dans le car une
crise mondiale globale
le clan globaliste a besoin pour pouvoir
être le baliste de couvrir l'ensemble
des acteurs donc il faut faire tomber la
russie pour faire tomber la russie il
faut attaquer l'espace qui est autour
d'elle c'est le tour de la biélorussie
et d'ailleurs on voit très bien que le
combat de la bido haussier de l'or ici
sont complètement liés puisque à chaque
fois que ce soit la commission
européenne où que ce soit
macron quand il s'agit de la question
des lourds us parallèlement l'on parle
également de la question de la vanille
autres la rustique ces deux dossiers
sont parfaitement liés dans une même
attaque menée actuellement pour
reprendre le contrôle du territoire
restant alors en tout cas le président
français a affirmé l'importance d'un
dialogue
avec la russie pour une transition en
douceur en biélorussie selon vous les
deux chefs d'état peuvent-ils s'accorder
sur ce point et à quelles conditions
si la russie s'accordent sur ce point
avec la france et qui parle donc au nord
du monde globaliste elle se promet le
même avenir que l'ukraine donc non pour
l'instant tout cas je ne pense pas à
tant que poutine se rend au pouvoir qu
un quelconque accord puisse être trouvé
si transition il doit y avoir c'est au
peuple biélorusse d'en décider ce n'est
certainement pas à macro de le faire
nous avons vu déjà les grandes réussites
de sa diplomatie au liban nous le voyons
général sur les terrains où il
intervient il et se tape pour la
biélorussie qu'elle n'accepte pas et
pour l'instant effectivement la majorité
ne semble pas prête à accepter ce genre
de choses alors l'organisation pour la
sécurité et la coopération en europe va
elle tenter une médiation une initiative
à laquelle vladimir poutine a
manifestement donné son accord
le président biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko acceptera-t-il de participer
à cette médiation visiblement compliqué
d'après ce que vous nous dites terminé
son est pour le moins compliqué parce
que pour qu'il y ait une médiation qui
ait un sens il faut qu'il puisse y avoir
un accord or là il peut pas y ait encore
un accord puisque c'est un choix qu'il
faut faire soit c'est le choix des mots
on globalise unilatérale défendu par
l'occident l'occurrence porté par macro
sur le plan européen
soit c'est un monde multilatéral porté
par la russie et poutine
en ce qui concerne nos est ce je vous
rappelle qu'elle avait déjà joué ce
merveilleux rôle de médiation en ukraine
en 2004 en 2014
en 2004 à l'époque de la révolution
orange c'est effectivement sous l'égide
de l'osce qui a été organisé le
troisième tour des élections électorales
et c'est sous l'égide de l'est ce qui a
été totalement détruit dans un premier
temps le système politique ukrainien
avec les conséquences derrière de maidan
que nous connaissons jaune
alors justement est ce que concrètement
on peut attendre d'eux après cette
médiation qui conduite par le sca de
nouvelles élections d'ici la fin de
l'année comme l'a dit iran's est la nati
un obscur ya
pour qui l'on arrive à à de nouvelles
élections avant la fin d'année il faut
que le cache un coq partent pour
l'instant l'inauguration de le caching
pourra lieu même s'il déplaît
profondément en occident tout ce qu'a pu
servir à masquer un sont des
déclarations à l'étranger une espèce de
parodie fantasque à l'intérieur du pays
ça fait quand même pas très sérieux si
maintenant chaque personne qui conteste
une élection peut elle demander
l'organisation d'un troisième tour à la
remise en cause de ces élections c'est
la fin en soi et du système politique et
du système d étape puisque dans ce cas
la légitimité ne viendra pas du
processus électoral et de l'élection des
peuples mais de la volonté la décision
la communauté internationale c'est
d'ailleurs exactement ce qui est demandé
et exigé par le nouvel ex finacement pas
besoin de la légitimité des états qui a
si renoncent à leur souveraineté dans
quelle existence
merci avoue karine béchec gaulle au fco
d'avoir partagé votre analyse je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur invité
à l'université d'état de moossou réunion
d'urgence ce soit au conseil de sécurité
de l'onu au sujet de la crise dans le
haut-karabagh ce territoire que se
disputent depuis 30 ans maintenant
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan troisième
jour d'affrontements depuis la reprise
des combats dimanche
le dernier bilan provisoire ferait état
de 96 victimes dont 16 civils mais il
pourrait être plus lourd bakou et erevan
affirme s'infliger de lourdes pertes
paris berlin et washington et moscou
appelle au cessez le feu
le kremlin qui demande à ankara devrait
pour la paix à la turquie qui se dit
prête à aider l'azerbaïdjan a recouvré
je cite ces terres occupées avec
guilmard aussi
les canon tonne toujours dans le caucase
du sud depuis ce dimanche les forces
azéries sont aux prises avec l'armée de
la république d'artsakh dans le
haut-karabagh une région séparatiste de
l'azerbaïdjan soutenus par l'arménie
voisine
bakou et erevan s'accusent d'avoir lancé
l'offensive et se rejettent la
responsabilité de la reprise des
hostilités ce lundi l'arménie a
d'ailleurs saisi la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme pour demander des
mesures provisoires d'urgence contre
l'azerbaïdjan
la demande est toujours en cours
d'examen selon l'instance de lui
l'europe qui s'est d'ailleurs inquiétée
d'un possible embrasement de la
transcaucasie jeu nous espérons et nous
demandons à chacun de faire tout son
possible pour éviter qu'une guerre
totale n'éclate
car c'est la dernière chose dont la
région a besoin l'escaladent autour du
nagorny karabach est très préoccupante
car elle comporte le risque d'une grave
escalade et de graves conséquences pour
la stabilité régionale
la position de l'union européenne est
claire en général à aucun interférences
externe elle sait c'est acceptable et on
doit éviter la lah interventions des
interférences de l'extérieur dans cette
conflit des interférences extérieures
qui ont été dénoncés par les autorités
de l'artsakh et des revan qui accuse la
turquie d'ingérence le ministère
arménien de la défense a même affirmé ce
mardi qu'un de ses chasseurs auraient
été abattus par un f-16 turcs ce
qu'ankara dément la turquie justement
qui ne compte pas jouer la carte de
l'apaisement alors que la totalité de
l'appareil diplomatique appel à la
désescalade
ankara préfère accuser son voisin
arménien et se range aux côtés de bakou
je condamne une fois de plus l'arménie
qui a attaqué le sol azerbaïdjanais la
turquie continuera d'être aux côtés de
son ami et frère azerbaïdjanais par tous
les moyens et de tout son coeur il est
temps de mettre un terme à la crise
régionale qui a commencé avec
l'occupation du haut karabagh de la
réalité les ministères
sans arménien et azerbaïdjanais la
région atteindra à nouveau la paix et le
calme
avec le retrait immédiat de l'armée ni
de la terre azerbaïdjanaise qu'elle a
occupée face à ce discours turc le
kremlin demande à ankara de s'abstenir
d'envenimer la situation
nous appelons tous les pays surtout nos
pays partenaires comme la turquie à
faire tout leur possible pour parvenir à
un cessez le feu et en réglement
pacifique de ce conflit
toutes sortes de déclarations sur un
soutien ou une activité militaire
quelconque ne font sans doute que mettre
de l'huile sur le feu quant aux victimes
les autorités du haut karabagh les
compte déjà en dizaines une estimation
probablement bien en-deça de la réalité
les ministères de la défense arménien et
azerbaïdjanais indique avoir infligé
plusieurs centaines de pertes humaines
dans les rangs adverses les avancées
militaires de chacun sont elles aussi
difficile à cerner le haut karabagh
déclare avoir repris des villages perdus
la veille quand bakou annonce gagner du
terrain
seule certitude ces nouveaux
affrontements au haut karabagh surpasse
déjà en intensité et en nombre de morts
les échauffourées de juillet dernier et
de 2016 quant au conflit du début des
années 90 il avait coûté la vie à 30
mille personnes
[Applaudissements]
un des tensions qui dure depuis le début
des années 90 donc et une guerre qui a
déjà fais 30000 morts revenons sur les
dates clés en images avec le récit de
cyrielle benavides bulbul liant et de
pieria de mazarine
[Musique]
rattaché à l'azerbaïdjan par staline en
1921 le nagorny karabach peuplée
majoritairement d'arméniens acquiert un
statut d'autonomie deux ans plus tard en
février 1988 de violences interethniques
éclate alors que l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan font encore partie de
l'urss en 1991 alors que le bloc
soviétique s'écroule le nagorny karabach
soutenu par yerevan proclame son
indépendance vis-à-vis de bakou le
conflit s'intensifie jusqu'au 17 mai
1994 lorsqu'un cessez le feu négocié par
moscou entre en vigueur
au total trente mille personnes sont
mortes et des millions d'autres ont fui
les combats
la même année l'organisation pour la
sécurité et la coopération en europe
créé le groupe de minsk constitué de la
russie de la france et des états unis
pour trouver une solution
malgré les pourparlers ya les vannes et
bakou ne parviennent pas à trouver un
accord sur le statut du territoire
considérés comme azerbaïdjanais par la
communauté international arménien et
azerbaïdjanais signent une déclaration
appelant à un règlement pacifique du
conflit
mais les tensions persistent et les
affrontements se multiplient
huit ans plus tard de violents combats
entre les armées des deux pays font
craindre une guerre ouverte au moins 110
personnes civiles et militaires trouvent
la mort
malgré un nouveau cessez le feu négocié
par moscou les combats meurtriers sur la
ligne de front restent fréquents le 12
juillet 2020 des heurts éclatent à la
frontière peu après que le président
azéri a menacé de quitter les
pourparlers de paix depuis des heurts
sont signalés quotidiennement selon les
bilans officiels
dix neuf personnes au moins ont perdu la
vie en juillet 2020 12
militaires et un civil azéri ainsi que
six soldats arméniens et pour en parler
nous sommes avec jean de gliniasty
directeur de recherche à l'institut de
relations internationales et
stratégiques jean de gliniasty merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors on vient de voir l'instant cette
zone le haut karabagh et depuis des
années l'objet de tensions entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
mais pourquoi la situation a dégénéré le
week-end dernier
ben je crois que il y aura de nombreux
éclats de ce genre puisque la situation
le statu quo est insupportable pour les
azerbaïdjanais puisque en gros l'arménie
occupe un peu moins de 20% du territoire
azerbaïdjanais et le camp plus la
légitimité du président aliev dès le
début de la dynastie aliev dès son
installation dans les années 90 et la
récupération du haut karabagh donc tant
qu'il n'y aura pas de solution négociée
eh bien nous aurons des incidents de ce
genre qui peuvent dégénérer en guerre
bien entendu à chaque fois alors la
russie appelle à un cessez le feu
immédiat d'autres pays en font de même
qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce que peut
craindre la communauté internationale
aujourd'hui que ce conflit déstabilise
finalement le caucase du sud
alors c'est un des rares cas où le
groupe chargé de faire de trop une
solution comporte à la fois les
etats-unis la russie et la france donc
on peut penser qu'il y aura une
convergence des efforts internationaux
pour pour assurer une médiation mais ça
c'est une médiation pour un
cessez-le-feu
la question qui se pose c'est vraiment
de trouver une solution durable
alors le groupe de minsk etats-unis
france russie avait proposé à madrid en
une solution qui prévoyait un référendum
l'autodétermination des cas rabat 6 qui
prévoyait la restitution des territoires
propre mazères vagina qui entoure le
haut karabakh et qui prévoyait la
sécurité du corridor de latchine qui
rejoint le haut karabakh et l'arménie
malheureusement cette solution qui était
une solution de bon sens d'ailleurs n'a
pas été acceptée ni par l'arménie ni par
l'azerbaïdjan et pourquoi ça ça bloque
au temps et ça bloque toujours
aujourd'hui
ben ça bloque parce que quel pays
accepterait d'avoir quasiment 20% son
territoire occupé et pas seulement
d'ailleurs les territoires la population
arménie arménienne est par ailleurs
comme vous l'avez très bien notées dans
votre rappel des dates importantes
ça fait depuis la république de
transcaucasie les comment dirais-je les
caravanes chine ne souhaitait pas
rentrer être inclus dans l'azerbaïdjan
et d'ailleurs gorbatchev et de bureau
politique en 19 188 ont refusé et une
énième demande du haut karabakh d'être
attaché à l'harmonie donc c'est un
problème qui devra nécessairement être
réglé par l'établissement d'un régime
très particulier de dieu au cabba que le
haut karabakh n'a pu obtenir que par la
force dans les années 90 alors il y a
également la turquie qui soutient
fermement l'azerbaïdjan est ce que ce
soutien complique aussi un peu plus la
donne pour la communauté internationale
oui c'est évident c'est évident parce
que la russie a maintenu jusqu'à présent
une position de ne
alité il ya ce qu'on appelle la doctrine
primakov qui disait que en gros la
russie était lié par un accord de
défense au sein de l'hôtel
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective à l'arménie mais ça ne
concernait que le territoire arménien ça
ne concernait pas le haut karabakh donc
la russie considérée comme légitime pour
jouer un rôle particulier pour obtenir
un cessez le feu ce qu'elle a fait la
fête tout le temps elle l'a fait en 94
elle l'a fait en 2016 elle leur fait la
ferme de début 2009 un don qu'elle est
un partenaire important pour la paix
mais la russie est aussi pourvoyeuse
d'armes aux uns comme aux autres
donc ça peut lui donner d'ailleurs ils
ont une autorité supplémentaires pour la
turquie c'est un peu de thym peu
différent la turquie disons
l'azerbaïdjan est un pays de langue
turcique qu'en dehors du russe que
beaucoup de gens parlent donc il est
relativement proche de la turquie
et on sait que rire doan a une politique
que certains qualifient de néo ottomane
ce qui n'est pas tout à fait exacts mais
en tout cas une politique d' influence
dans les pays de l'asie centrale qui
parle qui parle le turc ou des langues
proches du turc
alors pour conclure en quelques mois une
réunion d'urgence à huis clos du conseil
de sécurité de l'onu doit avoir lieu
dans un peu plus d'une heure maintenant
qu'est-ce qui peut en ressortir
selon vous je crois que l'unanimité sera
plus facile à obtenir puisque comme je
le disais les états unis et les russes
sont parties prenantes et les français
donc que mais une unanimité en fait
concrètement ça veut dire que la russie
dans son travail de médiation
appuyez sur le groupe de minsk or a le
soutien et la légitimité d'un accord du
conseil de sécurité pour essayer
d'obtenir un accord qui à ce stade ne
sera pas
accord de cessez-le-feu une fois de plus
merci beaucoup jean de gliniasty pour
votre éclairage je rappelle que vous
êtes directeur de recherche à l'institut
de relations internationales et
stratégiques et les arméniens de france
plus précisément les arméniens de paris
se sont réunis devant l'ambassade de
l'azerbaïdjan ce soir répondant à
l'appel du conseil de coordination des
organisations arméniennes de france ils
ont été une centaine à se rassembler
brandissant les drapeaux de l'arménie et
du haut karabagh tous demandent le
cessez le feu de cette guerre qu'ils
disent envers la région d'arsac mais
également vers l'arménie pour mourad
papazian le co président du ccas un pays
ami de la france qui plus est membre de
l'onu ne peut pas rester sans aide
extérieure
nous sommes là pour condamner la guerre
condamné le régime guerrier d'erdogan et
d'aliev puisque dans cette guerre les
deux états font ensemble durant
contrôleur à la barre et contre
l'arménie et nous sommes là pour
demander à la communauté internationale
faire cesser cette guerre et de
sanctionner l'intermezzo il est
inadmissible qu'un état membre de l'onu
attaque un autre état membre de l'onu
est resté avec nous sur rt france dans
quelques instants nous ferons un point
sur la situation sanitaire en france au
sein des hôpitaux ni les manifestations
de médecins ou personnels médicaux dont
empêcher la suppression de plus de 3400
lits d'hospitalisation en 2009
et puis direction israël le pays a
enregistré le plus fort taux de
contamination coronavirus au cours des
deux dernières semaines
le rpt confinement et et prolongé on
voit tout de suite dans un instant tout
ça dans un instant rester avec nous sur
rd france
[Musique]
comment on devient jean louis etienne
parce que vous êtes un héros pour plein
d'enfants je rêvais de faire des
expéditions se trouve savoir ce que
c'était et l'arrivée au pôle nord
quelques années après je me souviens
très bien du moment où je me suis dit
mais ça ça va être mal ce parcours là
vous a placé dans la bataille écologique
le réchauffement climatique est une
réalité quand on va bien on a trente
sept cantons à un degré de plus de 38 en
médecine à une fabrique une petite
fièvre couvre quelque chose la planète l
année là aujourd'hui chacun dans ses
activités impact la nature impacter
notre question environnementale
le risque c'est évidemment le
réchauffement climatique
mais l'autre risque c'est aussi la
réduction de l'activité économique jean
jaurès disait une phrase que j'aime
beaucoup aller à l'idéal quittant
comprenant le réel
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même le
corps n'avait russa a une odeur c'est
pas l'odeur du virus que des chiens
cherche c'est l'odeur de ce que fait le
virus dans l'organisme c'est quoi toute
fiabilité du projet ne serait ce qu'avec
dix nations nocives entre 92 et 98 5%
elle fonctionne bien ça permet un d'être
rapide d'être non invasif et puis
d'avoir le résultat de façon instantanée
avec un coût qui est quand même bien
moindre plus que sur les coûts actuels
d'épaisseur on va pas sauver l'humanité
souffrent pour révolutionner les choses
avec le travail qu'on fait aux peut-être
faire en sorte qu fasse appel à savoir
faire qui est un savoir-faire médical
aussi dans un domaine un peu différente
et celui de l'animal mais après tout
l'homme c'est un animal comme boulot
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'une entreprise zombies des
entreprises que l'on maintient sous
perfusion combien sont-elles vous avez
plein d'entreprises aujourd'hui qui sont
des entreprises zombies et y en a plein
qui vont le devenir avec les mesures
qu'on est en train de prendre ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire dès le départ c'était
être capable d'analyser les bilans des
entreprises pour savoir lesquels
souffrait simplement du confinement ou
du ralentissement de l'activité il est
qu'elle était déjà en état de deux morts
avancé on est en train de tuer
l'économie et vous avez une façon de
relancer l'économie qui est beaucoup
plus saine que ce qui est annoncé là et
qui évite ce genre de problème c'est de
baisser les impôts de production
laissons les impôts sur les entreprises
qui marchent et donc qui font du
résultat celles qui sont déjà zombies
elles font pas de résultat donc vous
pouvez baisser les impôts vous n'allez
pas leur donner de l'argent en faire
[Musique]
oui
entre 800 et 1000 tonnes de fuel se sont
déversés dans les eaux turquoises
mauricienne ce qu'il faudrait étendre
l'enquète aux autorités portuaires voir
plus haut nous devra lancer une enquête
d'une ouvrages devront maintenant
établir la chaîne de responsabilités
nationales
il faut savoir que la partie arrière du
bateau contient encore environ 50 à 100
tonnes de fioul donc ça pourrait aussi
actuellement se fracasser et causé un
deuxième déversement de pétrole plus ça
arrive après les convives 19
nous avons un secteur hôtelier et
touristique du vin jaune où en sont
vraiment des impacts de la catastrophe
sur l'environnement marin mais aussi sur
les populations niveau de la santé vont
se faire ressentir pendant des décennies
il faut s'attendre aujourd'hui à maurice
aussi un désastre sanitaire
il est catastrophe on a vécu voilà
pourquoi je suis pas si pessimiste
[Musique]
le 14 juillet 2015 et signe à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président avait décidé de rompre
l'accord et d'imposer son régime de
sanctions au niveau international sur
1000 iran en grave difficulté au plan
économique et social pour la chine c'est
une très belle opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avaient ils un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en tous genres par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes ne les avons nous pas
pousser dans les bras d'un partenaire
qui va en profiter pour faire de l'iran
sa tête de pont au moyen orient
[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi 29 septembre 2001 les hôpitaux en
première ligne face aux coded est sur le
pont depuis plusieurs mois pour réclamer
davantage de moyens
mais les manifestations des médecins et
des personnels médicaux n'ont pas
empêché la suppression de plus de 3400
lits d'hospitalisation en 2019
comme le révèle une étude du ministère
de la santé publié ce mardi en israël
leur confinement est prolongée au delà
des trois semaines annoncé une mise sous
cloche imposé il ya dix jours et qui se
poursuivra donc au delà du 11 octobre
mais l'état hébreu a enregistré le plus
fort taux de contamination au monde au
cours des deux dernières semaines écoles
synagogues et lieux de loisirs resteront
fermés aux états unis les candidats sur
le qui vive prêt à en découdre donald
trump face à joe biden cette nuit 3
heures heure française pour le premier
duel télévisé entre les deux candidats à
la maison blanche
à presque un mois du scrutin du 3
novembre le dialogue s'annonce musclé
entre crises sanitaires et économiques
tensions raciales ou encore fiche
d'imposition du président américain
[Musique]
alors que le gouvernement multiplie les
mesures de restriction pour endiguer
l'épidémie de kobe de 19 le milieux
hospitaliers s'alarment de la pression
qui risque de s'accentuer sur ses
effectifs beaucoup parmi les personnels
hospitaliers ont l'impression que les
leçons n'ont pas été tirées de la
première vague et craignent de manquer
de moyens lit la femme ou fermeture des
bars des restaurants ou encore des
salles de sport pas un jour ne passe
sans une nouvelle mesure de restriction
pour l'exécutif
il s'agit de ne pas saturer les hôpitaux
un seul but préserver au maximum un
système de santé déjà très fragile mais
il est peu question du nombre de places
disponibles dans les établissements de
santé et de mesures d'urgence qui n'ont
pas été prises depuis la première vague
c'est en tout cas ce que pense le
professeur juvin chef de service des
urgences de l'hôpital georges pompidou à
paris il ya un chiffre à savoir avant le
mois de mars on avait 5000 lits de
réanimation et là nous avons 5008
rénovation pas plus face à un système de
santé qui s'est appauvrie ces trois
dernières décennies
le professeur réclament des mesures plus
concrètes du matériel du personnel
supplémentaire et délits en service de
réanimation mais ces demandes ne semble
pas être à l'ordre du jour ce que les
français ne comprennent pas qu'ils nous
écoutent et nous mêmes c'est pourquoi on
était à 5000 lits en réanimation et y
monte à 10 millions comment se fait-il
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas dix mille
lits spécifique réanimation notre pays
de manière pérenne mais parce que vous
ne pouvez pas du jour au lendemain
passer de cinq à dix mille et nous a des
visions mois aux différents elle les
conclusions du ségur de la santé dévoilé
fin juillet prévoit bien des
recrutements et 4000 création de lits à
la demande créée ponctuellement pour
faire face un pic épidémique ou une
hausse de l'activité saisonnière
à titre de comparaison ce chiffre de
4000 lits correspond à peu de choses
près et même un peu moins aux fermetures
de lits qui ont eu lieu pour la seule
année 2010 8 4200 très exactement
en juin dernier des cliniques de rennes
par exemple signalait n'avoir obtenu
aucune autorisation pour créer des lits
en réanimation il dénonçait alors des
postures hostile
au secteur privé la bretagne est la
région de france la moins bien dotées en
capacité de lits de réanimation
nous disposons de 162 lits de
réanimation quand une région à
population comparable comme la normandie
en propose 225
le 27 septembre le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand a lancé un vibrant
message je fais un appel notamment dans
les ehpad où nous avons besoin de
renforts
nous avons des postes ouverts qui sont
des postes financés encore non pourvus
alors que la deuxième vague menace plus
que jamais on est en droit de se
demander pourquoi rien ou si peu n'a été
fait depuis le déconfinement d'autres
pays ont tiré des leçons bien plus vite
que nous aux etats unis la californie a
augmenté de 900 places sa capacité en
réanimation
plus près de chez nous l'italie dès le
mois de mai a commencé à doubler ses
capacités de lits de réanimation et à
recruter vingt mille personnes
depuis des années à la france figurent
parmi les mauvais élèves en terme de
places en réanimation avec 11,6 pour
cent mille habitants elle arrive par
exemple derrière la croatie et la
bulgarie et s'il n'est jamais trop tard
il faudra plus que des promesses et des
médailles d'honneur décernée aux braves
personnels hospitaliers pour attirer de
nouveaux candidats sur ces éventuels
nouveaux postes espérons que ces
derniers ont également du matériel et
des lits pour accueillir les futurs
malades
peut-être très bientôt et pour en parler
nous sommes avec rodrigo martinez parra
vice-président du collectif inter
urgence rodrigo martinez parra merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors trois mille quatre cents lits
d'hospitalisation complète ont donc été
fermé en 2019 dans les établissements de
santé français dans le même temps 1500
places d'hospitalisation par céder elles
ont été créées
vous qui êtes à nouveau en première
ligne face au regain de l'épidémie
comment est-ce que vous réagissez face à
ces chiffres bonsoir va tout d'abord on
va dire que on a vraiment l'impression
en tant que personnel de pas avoir été
entendu savoir que collectif
interrogeant ça fait deux ans que nous
sommes là en train de nous de nous
battre pour avoir plus de lits plus de
moyens et il y avait là la question de
la revalorisation des salaires
qui permettait de rendre attractif en
fait les postes et pouvoir recruter du
personnel à savoir qu'actuellement il ya
7500 postes rien qu'à l'assistance
publique qui sont à pourvoir et on
pourra même si sur le ségur promettre
d'embauché 7500 d'autres personnes
j'ai du mal à voir comment on va pouvoir
recruter du personnel
si l'hôpital n'est pas attractif
on pensait que le coc vidal est un petit
peu temporiser et on avait entendu le
président qu'il avait dit que quoi qu'il
en coûte
il a sorti des belles phrases de
communication quoi qu'il en coûte
on sait que par exemple la fermeture de
glee ça devient catastrophique nord
l'ensemble du territoire on voit que
finalement il ya vraiment une perte pour
les personnes de possibilité d'accéder à
des soins
lorsqu'il ya les hôpitaux ou des
services qui seront fermés en plus il
faut pas oublier que le celi qui sont
fermés actuellement il y à des services
qui sont fermées par manque de personnel
donc si on rajoute et on accumule tous
les lits fermés plus les livres où il
manque du personnel qui doit être fermé
par manque de soignants
ça devient catastrophique alors on
entendait tout à l'heure le ministre de
la santé
olivier verrey chez nos confrères d'rtl
dire vous ne pouvez pas du jour au
lendemain passé de 5000 à 10000 lee
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez
bon après il faut se donner les moyens à
un moment il faut savoir ce qu'on veut
certes on peut pas réouvrir des lits de
réanimation en claquant des doigts
mais par contre on peut former du
personnel on peut on peut essayer de
motiver les gens à vouloir se
spécialiser en réanimation
on peut on peut inciter les personnes à
avoir des promotions professionnelles
chose qui a été un petit peu mis de côté
depuis un certain temps c'est à dire
quand on aide soignant vouloir accéder à
la promotion officielle ça devient de
plus en plus compliqué on aurait pu tout
simplement ne pas fermer des lits
prendre des décisions à un moment à bras
le corps et ses dires on temporise on
voit ce qu'on peut faire parce que
bien souvent les lits lorsque l'on parle
de service et sa loi avec le collectif
en local de gens c'est bat pour
conserver leur hôpital de proximité pour
conserver justement ces services et
finalement on se rend compte que rien
n'a été fait ils ne soient pas entendus
et là ça devient catastrophique parce
que finalement quelques est ce qu'on
doit faire pour pouvoir être entendue
mais justement parce que finalement ce
malaise dans le milieu hospitalier ils
datent pas de la crise du coc vie 19 ça
fait des mois voire des années que il ya
des grèves des manifestations pour
alerter sur la population
comment est ce que vous comprenez que
finalement ces manifestations n'ont pas
inversé la tendance
bah on se dispute pas en fait c'est pour
ça que nous sommes encore en grève et on
va continuer à se mobiliser
je réponds qu est ce qu on vous répond
finalement depuis toutes ces années
en fait la réponse est très simple c'est
que nous nous travaillons et nous avons
vocation au service public et nous
sommes clairs dans notre mission ce
qu'on veut c'est pouvoir travailler dans
des conditions convenables pour pouvoir
accueillir des patients est ce qu'on
veut en fait c'est que peu importe le
statut socioéconomique et peu importe où
vous vous trouvez en france vous
puissiez accéder à des soins de qualité
et pour ça il faut mettre les moyens
la vision que en art en face c'est
purement une vision économique et donc
on a on a un vrai problème de
communication parce que nous on parle de
patients on parle de l'art de soigner de
prendre en charge comme vous aimeriez
pris en charge ou l'un de vos proches
et finalement ce voile heurter à un mur
d'incompréhension avec des gens qui nous
parlent de statistiques et qui voit un
cas une vision de rentabilité les seins
c'est à dire plus que éprouvant
d'essayer de leur faire comprendre que
finalement un un soin technique
si on le fait avec une personne âgée ou
une paire ou un enfant tout simplement
ça risque de prendre un peu plus de
temps il faut peut-être réfléchir sur la
qualité sur sur ce qu'on veut en fait
dans cette société est ce qu'on veut
c'est rendre les soins et l'hôpital
humains aussi bien pour personnel mais
surtout pour les patients et finalement
on se rend compte que les pouvoirs
publics ont vraiment une vision
un souci de rentabilité et sans l'a vu
avec la succession de décisions
politiques qui ont été prises en compte
notamment la tarification à l'acte et
des choses un peu plus compliqué en fait
on a l'impression mais ça fait deux ans
que le collectif intérieur gens c'est en
grève on a le collectif inter hôpitaux
qui est avec nous vous avez tous les
corporations enfin vous avez les iade
ibode vous avez la maternité vous avez
toutes les professions confondues
on est tous en train de crier que
l'hôpital ne va pas qu'il faut sauver
l'hôpital public et finalement on n'a
aucune aucune réponse qui nous
satisfasse
alors pour conclure il y a deux mois il
a eu les accords du ségur de la santé
alors je vais le rappeler
il prévoit 8 milliards de hausses de
salaires 15000 recrutement 6 milliards
d'investissements et 13 milliards de
reprise de dette des hôpitaux le
ministre de la santé au lit et veyran
rassemblés mercredi à aujourd'hui les
parties prenantes pour un point d'étape
alors où est ce qu'on en met des
engagements gouvernementaux aujourd'hui
ben concrètement on attend toujours
voilà je crois qu'ils sont les
perspectives des perspectives mais vous
savez ça fait tellement longtemps que
quand on entend beaucoup de choses et
que finalement concrètement notre
quotidien ne change pas il n'y a pas si
longtemps lundi dernier on a une réunion
voilà on pourrait citer les hôpitaux les
urgences les unes après les autres
il manque du personnel un exemple enfin
l'âge il ya 120 nuit supplémentaire pour
les aides-soignants à l'hôtel dieu il y
en a 45 au niveau des infirmiers on ne
veut pas recruter c'est pas à défaut de
post de gens qui postulent c'est juste
que enfin il faut comprendre aussi
qu'ils essaient de l'hôpital n'est plus
attrayant et les gens baisser les bras
nous sommes épuisés nous sommes fatigués
de tout voir de devoir dire les choses
et de ne pas voir finalement de
changement parce que finalement on a
beau on est toujours confronté à la même
à la même problématique
il manque du personnel et ça on peut le
demander dans tous les services il
manque du matériel quand on
rocard qui dysfonctionnent quand on voit
des patients qui sont hospitalisés sur
les bras car faute de lits il faut
comprendre que la problématique est bien
plus profonde que ce qu'on veut laisser
paraître enfin quand vous êtes en
province et que vous n'avez pas accès à
des services à des spécialités
ça devient problématique quand vous
voyez nos collègues en ehpad qui ne
peuvent pas soigner la paix les
personnes aidées accompagné comme il se
doit et avoir une quantité de travail
qui les épuise en comprend il ya un turn
over il faut juste se poser la question
quand vous voyez que dans les équipes
d'urgence les gens restent trois ans qui
atteint 9 heures de trois ans que
l'exercice de la profession infirmière
ces cinq ans il faut se poser les bonnes
questions effectivement le métier
n'attire plus de métier n'attire plus
effectivement on a bien entendu le
malaise au sein des personnels
hospitaliers aujourd'hui merci à vous
rodrigo martinez alors à elle je
rappelle que vous êtes vice-président du
collectif inter urgence merci votre
l'allemagne va limiter le nombre de
participants des fêtes dans l'espace
public et privé et celles annonces
d'angela merkel aujourd'hui à l'issue
d'une réunion avec les dirigeants des 16
états régionaux
depuis le mois de juin le nombre de
contaminations quotidienne a triplé
outre-rhin
les explications de rania berrada la
situation de crise
réunion de crise ce mardi la chancelière
allemande a convoqué les dirigeants des
16 états régionaux
en cause l'augmentation des
contaminations quotidienne outre hre à
leurs moyennes a triplé depuis le mois
de juin pour tenter de freiner la
propagation du virus en gala merkel a
annoncé que les rassemblements privé
serait désormais limité à 25 personnes
ce dans l'espace public à 50
les retours de voyages et les fêtes
privées qu'elle soit à la maison ou dans
l'espace public sont à l'origine de
nombreux foyers d'infection il faut que
l'on réagisse
d'autres mesures devraient également
être prises dans les restaurants les
cafés et les bars où chaque client doit
laisser ses coordonnées des amendes d'un
minimum de 50 euros pourrait être
infligée ici des personnes livre des
informations erronées et dans certaines
régions particulièrement frappés par le
virus
la vente d'alcool pourrait être
provisoirement limités face à la
résurgence de l'épidémie de covin 19 le
gouvernement en appelle une nouvelle
fois la responsabilité des citoyens et
au respect des gestes barrières des
gestes que les allemands semblent avoir
assimilé jeu vient à peine d'être
diplômés cette année et c'était un
véritable challenge
tout était différent il a fallu passer
des examens en portant le masque mais ça
a marché
écoutez je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
pays qui sont plus touchés que
l'allemagne mais c'est aussi dû au fait
qu'on ait réagi très vite ici j'étais au
canada au moment du pic du virus en mars
et j'ai constaté que là bas les gens
réagissaient lentement en allemagne le
nombre quotidien de nouvelles infections
a dépassé la barre des 2000 selon
l'institut de veille sanitaire robert
koch
à ce jour outre rhin près de 9500
personnes sont mortes du coït 19 et site
est l'un des pays les plus touchés par
le govic 19 au début de la pandémie mais
aujourd'hui l'italie qui déplore plus de
35000 mort fait désormais figure de
modèle à les dirigeants transalpins peut
même se targuer d'un nombre de
contaminations bien plus faible que dans
d'autres états européens
mais si l'om est salue les dirigeants
pour leur gestion de la crise la
situation reste bien sûr sous haute
surveillance et au combat
en italie se faire pointer par un
pistolet peut être synonyme de sécurité
on contrôle la température de tous les
clients à leur arrivée si lille doivent
se désinfecter les mains et chaque
client de remplir un formulaire avec
leurs noms et coordonnées pour être
contacter en cas de besoin
des mesures de prévention que les
italiens ont appris à appliquer
rigoureusement et qui font leurs preuves
après avoir subi de plein fouet la
première vague de l'épidémie
l'italie récolte aujourd'hui les fruits
de sa politique volontariste un
confinement mis en place plus rapidement
des mesures plus strictes et réactivable
à souhait
un dispositif de traçage efficace les
raisons de ce petit miracle italiens
sont nombreuses
des précautions souvent similaires à
celles des pays voisins mais d'une bien
meilleure efficacité
le président de la république italienne
sergio matar est là il voit le sérieux
de ses compatriotes
ce que confirme c'est infectiologues
genou en général ne sommes pas contents
parce qu'on dit toujours de faire encore
plus attention mais en réalité les
citoyens italiens ont été très
respectueux de toutes les règles quand
je vois au journal télévisé les images
d'autres vies les européennes
je vois beaucoup plus de gens son masque
qu'en italie une prise de conscience
collective qui a permis à l'italie
enregistré en moyenne seulement 37 cas
pour 100000 habitants c'est 15 derniers
jours contre 235 en france et 320 en
espagne par ailleurs le gouvernement
s'est montré très prudent lors du
déconfinement et n'a pas hésité à
revenir sur ses décisions
lorsque les contaminations sont repartis
à la hausse
mais ces dispositions n'empêchent pas le
corps médical de rester très attentif
[Musique]
ces derniers jours je tirais depuis une
quinzaine de jours nous avons assisté à
une hausse des cas de contamination et
certains malades avec symptômes ont dû
être hospitalisés chez nous et nous
avons dû faire face à cette nouvelle
augmentation de personnes contaminées
il fait une tendance qui reste à
relativiser l'italie comptait moins de
deux milles nouvelles contaminations
journalières quand l'espagne ou la
france ont déploré plus de 10000 ces
derniers jours alors règles restrictives
concernant les bars et des restaurants
en france une partie de la région de
madrid qui se recombinent les mesures
pour tenter d'endiguer la pandémie se
multiplient illustration avec israël qui
prolongera son confinement au delà des
trois semaines annoncé a mis sous cloche
imposé il ya dix jours et qui ira donc
au delà du 11 octobre
l état hébreu a enregistré le plus fort
taux de contamination au monde au cours
des dernières semaines d'école synagogue
et lieux de loisirs resteront fermés le
premier ministre benyamin netanyahu doit
s'exprimer à l'occasion du dernier jour
de l'assemblée générale des nations
unies à new york
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
muriel haïm présidente de la fondation
france israël
muriel bonsoir merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors après la
première vague en avril dernier
tout le monde a salué la bonne gestion
de la pandémie de l'état hébreu avec des
restrictions forte notamment pourtant
aujourd'hui israël est le pays qui
compte le plus de contamination sur les
deux dernières semaines alors comment
est-ce qu'on peut le comprendre ce qui
s'est passé c'est en effet au départ
quand elle des ailes à confiner très
rapidement fermé ses frontières a confié
les traits et ça a été très efficace
après on a eu le poids de l'économie
puisque vous savez c'est toujours un
mais change entre la santé et l'économie
mais comme lui ça veut dire quoi parce
qu'on est passé en vrai que vous preniez
était un pays qui n'avait que 4 % de
chaumont on est passé brutalement à 20%
qui dit chômage en israël au filet
social est beaucoup moins généreux quand
autant france à partir de
ça génère une certaine pauvreté et où le
gouvernement avait confiné peut être un
peu trop vite et c'est ce qu'il
reconnaît maintenant pour permettre aux
gens de retourner travailler alors
rapport à des réalités
alors justement ces réalités économiques
ce nouveau confinement est ce qu'il est
source de divisions au sein de la
population est ce que le sujet s'invite
dans le débat politique
d'abord le confinement et à un certain
nombre de deux entreprises peuvent
continuer à travailler des entreprises
qui sont les télés travail et bien
entendu recommandé un certain nombre
d'entreprises de moins de 12 personnes
peuvent travailler en de manière
séquentielle
c'est à dire un certain nombre de
travailleurs et en suit en faisant les
gestes barrière en aménageant des
espaces ça bien entendu on va évidemment
il ya une certaine tension puisqu'il ya
certes un goût qui refusent ce
confinement et là on parle
essentiellement de deux groupes je ne
veux pas dire les religions parce que le
monde religieux n'est pas mort de vos
chaînes et à l'intérieur du monde
religieux il ya des gens qui respecte
complètement avec des rabbins qui vit à
l'heure à leurs voyants effet vous devez
respecter les consignes et entre autres
le ministre de l'intérieur qui fait
partie d'un mouvement
la parti religieux lui est resté au
gouvernement en disant à son parti en
effet de soutenir la politique du
gouvernement
nous soutenons cette action que
confinement les gestes barrières pour ce
qu'ils peuvent sortir
donc ça c'est quelque chose de très
clair il ya une fraction du monde
religieux la conduite des artworks de
ces deux instances de la communauté
offre qui en effet n'a tête n'adhère pas
à ces mesures avait pas d'autres
contaminations shore les pourtant ils
ont payé un prix parce que parmi le
nombre de décès il faut savoir qu'ils
seraient là quand même même si en ce
moment il a un taux de contamination
importe ce qu'en a quand même un taux de
décès j'aime c'est toujours trop j'ai
appris quelques m17 quelque chose qu'on
aurait voulu éviter bien entendu mais on
est pratiquement 10 millions d'habitants
il ya 1500 ont ce décès avec lauré à ce
jeu est ce que la situation est hors de
contrôle aujourd'hui la situation
sanitaire est ce que les hôpitaux sont
débordés comment est-ce que ça se passe
de vito ne sont pas débordés aujourd'hui
les hôpitaux commencent à en effet être
plein sur le plan sur dans les
départements peuvent ils ils sont en
train de rouvrir d'autres départements
c'est-à-dire de créer des espaces
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui est en
train de se fermer pour le moment
aujourd'hui mais des hôpitaux ne sont
pas débordés
ce sens à la limite de leurs de ce
qu'ils peuvent on est c'est pour ça que
l'on entre autres avec les de l'armée il
ya des nouvelles sculptures de son qui
s'inscrit alors running gag rule
coordinateur de la lutte contre le colis
de 19 à présenter ses excuses pour
n'avoir pu empêcher un confinement à ce
qu'il est le seul responsable selon vous
vous savez que ça ne peut jamais être un
homme qui est responsable il ya eu une
enquête très intéressante et il 52% de
la population enfin dans cet échantillon
a dit que la population était
responsable 48% a dit que c'était le
gouvernement mais 52% a reconnu sa
propre responsabilité je pense que c'est
très intéressant parce que finalement
les mesures barrières on parlait de la
communauté ultra-orthodoxe tout à
l'heure mais dans la population générale
est ce que les gens ont du mal finir
finalement à respecter des gestes
barrières non les gens mais des masques
et léger en effet même dans les
manifestations ou respecter et distant
ça c'est quelque chose qu'ils espèrent
il ya une autre
un autre communauté où il ya aussi des
petits kloster c'est en effet dans la
population arabe israélienne est donc à
ce niveau là mais les maires ont souvent
étaient contents qu'on leur démontre
qu'on leur a imposé un certain nombre de
mesures de confinement
parce que ça les a aussi bien les faire
passer dans leur population ça c'est
quelque chose de très important
merci beaucoup allez-y juillet allez-y
oui il y a eu quand même une très bonne
coopération entre médecins israël et un
médecin palestinien les médecins
parisiens et même de
hazard étant venus se faire former soit
pour point de passage d'erez soit à
l'hôpital et beersheva mais quand même
des très bonnes
merci beaucoup muriel d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
présidente de la fondation france israël
et dans quelques instants nous
évoquerons la campagne présidentielle
américaine john hayden donald trump se
retrouve cette nuit pour un premier
débat télévisé très attendu une
rencontre de 90 minutes où les bilans
respectifs des deux candidats seront
notamment abordées à rester avec nous
sur rtl
[Musique]
comment on devient jean louis etienne
parce que vous êtes un héros pour plein
d'enfants je rêvais de faire les
expéditions se trouve savoir ce que
c'était et l'arrivée au pôle nord
quelques années après je me souviens
très bien du moment où je me suis dit
mais ça ça va être mal ce parcours là
vous a placé dans la bataille écologique
le réchauffement climatique est une
réalité quand on va bien on a trente
sept cantons à un degré de plus de 38 en
médecine à une fabrique une petite
fièvre couvre quelque chose la planète l
année là aujourd'hui chacun dans ses
activités impact la nature impacter
notre les questions environnementales
le risque c'est évidemment le
réchauffement climatique
mais l'autre risque c'est aussi la
réduction de l'activité économique jean
jaurès dizaine d'une phrase que j'aime
beaucoup aller à l'idéal quittant
comprenant le réel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le corps n'avait russa a une odeur c'est
pas l'odeur du virus que les chiens
cherche c'est l'odeur de ce que fait le
virus dans l'organisme
c'est quoi toute fiabilité du projet ne
serait ce qu'au business et on oscille
entre 92 et 98 5%
elle fonctionne bien ça permet un d'être
rapide d'être non invasif et puis
d'avoir le résultat de façon instantanée
avec un coût qui est quand même bien
moindre plus que sur les coûts actuels
d'épaisseur on va pas sauver l'humanité
souffrent pour révolutionner les choses
avec le travail qu'on fait ou peut-être
faire en sorte qu fasse appel à savoir
faire qui savoir-faire médical aussi
dans un domaine un peu différente et
celui de l'animal mais après tout
l'homme c'est un animal comme boulot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des soul unis vers une forme risquant
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent ces
gens qui avaient envie de transmettre
quelque chose alors jean francky
tout
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
une trappe est vraiment passé à côté du
problème et dans mes souvenirs c'est la
première fois qu'on assiste à des
manifestations de masse où la majorité
des américains sont sympathisants de ces
mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences cessent selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il ya une impunité assumer il y a une
culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez il est
21h30 heure française à la campagne
présidentielle américaine entre dans une
nouvelle phase aujourd'hui donald trump
et joe biden s'affrontent ce soir lors
du premier débat télévisé en vue de
l'élection présidentielle du 3 novembre
prochain l'occasion pour les deux
candidats de débattre dans l'ohio l'un
des fameux état pivot où se joue
l'élection hélène masquelier ce soir à
21h heure locale des dizaines de
millions d'américains auront les yeux
rivés sur cleveland où a lieu le premier
débat entre le président donald trump et
son rival joe biden l'ancien
vice-président de barack obama est
aujourd'hui l'espoir de tous ceux qui
espèrent la défaite du milliardaire le
démocrate de 77 ans qui au nom des
précautions sanitaires mène une campagne
plus discrète que celle tambours
battants de l'ex-homme d'affaires sera
comme rarement sous les projecteurs
connu pour ses maladresses verbales joe
biden a admis que la confrontation
télévisée entre les deux hommes serait
difficile j'espère que je ne me
laisserai pas amorcé dans une bagarre
avec ce type car c'est le seul endroit
où il est à l'aise
donald trump de son côté ne cesse de
railler l'absence de dynamisme de son
rival qu'il surnomme joe lando remis
comme il ya cinq ans le président adepte
des débats animés à assurer ses arrières
en début de semaine celui qui est le
favori c'est ce lipide jo je suis celui
qui est sans expérience je fais cela
seulement depuis quelques années cela
fait plus de quarante sept ans qu'est
dans l'arène alors que le début de son
mandat a affiché de bons chiffres
notamment ce qui concerne le chômage
une grande partie de l'électorat
pourrait reprocher aux milliardaires la
mauvaise gestion de l'épidémie qui a
fait plus de deux cent mille morts dans
le pays
les questions raciales et la violence
figureront aussi parmi les six sujets du
débat tout comme la succession de ruth
bader ginsburg à la cour suprême
je pense que les partisans du président
trump vont dire vous voyez il est fort
il a raison le vice président biden est
faible il cache quelque chose et je
pense que les partisans du vice
président biden vont regarder le débat
et dire vous voyez je le savais bail
d'un effort il est calme il unit trump a
perdu pied ils inventent des choses il
est clairement corrompus je pense que
les deux parties
vont s'auto déclaré vainqueur après ce
premier duel de 90 minutes deux autres
débats sont encore prévues pour
départager les deux candidats avant la
présidentielle du 3 novembre
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis standford aux états unis avec
allen
or il est avocat c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur à l'énorme merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
le premier débat entre trump hebeisen à
quoi doit-on s'attendre qui a le plus à
perdre selon vous qu'on puisse
s'attendre à quelque chose de précis la
situation est imprévisible
donald trump est un batelier et on peut
s'attendre à avoir un grand numéro ce
soir et on pourrait s'attendre second
temps est-ce que c'était pas se contente
de d'introduire les débats précédents on
ne peut pas vraiment savoir s'il
s'agirait vraiment d'une véritable
discussion quant à l'avenir des états
unis alors justement après les dernières
révélations par le new york times sur
les 750 euros d'impôts payés par le
président américain en 2016 et 2017
joe biden vient de publié il ya quelques
heures ces dernières feuilles d'impôts
le duel at il déjà commencé finalement
que le problème des impôts suis tonale
30 depuis le tout début de sa campagne
et même depuis le tout début de son
mandat
donc ces soutiens sont des soutiens il
est beaucoup d'histoires fracassantes
sur l'administration trump beaucoup de
surprises et beaucoup de surprises
interviennent souvent à proximité de
l'élection mais les soutiens de donald
trump ne croise tout simplement pas à
ces histoires pense qu'il s'agit d'un
battage médiatique
ils se sont écartés des faits des
preuves saveurs ton sorte de
partisanisme aveugle alors quelle est
l'ambiance aux états unis
ni comment les différents médias
décrypte cet événement l'ambiance est
très tendue il ya déjà beaucoup de
problèmes lakovic 19 fait toujours rage
il ya des problèmes des conflits entre
races
il y a également un gros problème avec
la police
et donc c'est tout un tas de sujets qui
s'ajoute aux problèmes économiques et
aux questions sur le confinement et la
fin éventuelle de confinement je pense
que l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir
des élections légitimes et d'avoir un
résultat aussi claire que possible afin
que le pays puisse continuer avec le
dirigeant quel qu'il soit alors quel
électorat
les deux hommes devront aller chercher
ce soit on sait que joe biden veut
reconquérir les ouvriers blancs par
exemple élection n'est pas une élection
à propos des parties il s'agit de
galvaniser les gens qui n'ont pas voté
aux dernières élections
l'administration obama a fait voter des
gens qui n'avaient jamais voté ou qui
avait arrêté de voter un débat ne permet
pas de changer d'avis et à peine plus
d'une heure une heure quarante-cinq cela
ne suffit pas pour changer sa vision du
monde
les électeurs ont déjà un candidat qui
les intéresse plus et de plus le
meilleur orateur n'est peut-être pas le
meilleur dirigeant
donc il ne faut pas penser que celui qui
remporte le débat devrait remporter des
élections
dany ciation n'a pas encore publié de
programmes pour la réélection alors que
les démocrates ont présenté un programme
très solide partie écrite et une partie
orale des démocrates protège obamacare
alors que l'administration de trump
essaye de s'en débarrasser c'est ce
genre de facteurs qui permet aux gens de
décider et je ne pense pas que le débat
de ce soir va changer la donne
sauf dans le cas dans le dans la mesure
où cela va donner plus d'élan à un des
candidats mais à part cela cela n'a pas
changé la dynamique politique du pays
pour conclure en quelques mots les
manifestations violentes se multiplient
aux etats-unis à qui profites t'elle en
vue des élections selon vous c'est une
question assez complexe mais je pense
que cela profite aux démocrates parce
que cesser ses manifestations arrivent
alors que donald trump est au pouvoir et
donald trump voudrait bien recevoir un
prix nobel de la paix alors qu'il n'a
même pas la paix dans son propre pays
est un problème
merci beaucoup à l'est nord d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat à stanford aux états
unis et pour continuer d'échanger sur le
duel trump biden attendu dans quelques
heures on retrouve nos invités l'un est
américain pro trump l'autre est français
et historien
[Musique]
et nous sommes avec randy yann aux
avocats président de république and over
6 france bonsoir à côté edouard husson
historiens alors un débat donc très
attendue dans quelques heures entre
donald trump et joe biden edouard husson
en 2016
c'était 84 millions de personnes qui
avaient regardé le débat entre trump et
clinton quatre ans plus tard les
américains mais aussi le monde entier
tout le monde a fait connaissance avec
le président des états unis est-ce que
l'engouement sera le même selon vous
pendant ce duel est pourquoi il me
semble si vous voulez que le il n'y a
pas eu véritablement de campagne ou en
tout cas elle a été très limitée par le
cos vide et en particulier par le fait
que joe biden qui est plus âgée que
donald trump est très protégée par les
siens vous savez quel républicains
pensent même que joe biden est fragile
voire malade qu'il n'est pas capable
d'assumer la fonction présidentielle et
donc on l'a très peu laissé sortir
lorsqu'il a fait des débats il avait peu
de gens quasiment personne dans l'est
dans les salles et donc c'est la
première fois que l'on va avoir un
affrontement donald trump lui est
beaucoup plus sorti il a eu des foules
considérables
il faut regarder les images comme en
2016 et donc il va falloir va falloir
profiter de cet événement parce que il y
aura peu d'affrontements réelle entre
les deux hommes c'est à dire que le
débat qui est habituellement le moment
de vérité va être encore plus important
que lors des présidentielles précédentes
en particulier des grands des grands
débats lorsqu'obama été élu la première
fois où lorsque trump a gagné il ya
quatre ans alors randy aloses alors que
donald trump
on l'apprend l'instant vient d'arriver à
cleveland entre la gestion du président
américain de la crise du coronavirus qui
a été montré du doigt l'économie qui va
mal les dernières
les nations par le new york times
concernant ce fameux montant de 750
euros d'impôts payés en 2016 et 2017 par
le président américain
quelle peut être la stratégie de donald
trump parce qu'il n'est pas affaibli
d'entrée de jeu sur vous il n'est pas du
tout à fait mais vous prenez par exemple
la reprise économique s'est jamais dans
l'histoire depuis cinq ans 60 ans qui
l'a peuvent faire réduire les taux de
chômage de 14 à huit et demi pour cent
c'est un record donc il faut savoir qui
est monsieur tron est un homme capable
de gérer des crises économiques des
grandes ampleurs d'une part pour le coc
vide
il n'a jamais abandonné les américains
il a assuré qu'ils auront les soins
nécessaires pendant toute cette crise et
que tout américain étaient pris en
charge
même s'il n'avait pas d'assurance ils
ont reçu des aides de l'état pour payer
le loyer
il a aussi a signé un décret pour
s'assurer que tout américain se sera pas
expulsé dès son habitation elle son
logement jusqu'à la fin de l'année
j'ai dit ok mais je trompe s'occupe des
du peuple américain
en même temps revenons sur les questions
de new york times
d'abord il faut savoir monsieur trempe a
fait donation de son salaire chaque
année ils travaillent gratuitement il
reçoit un de l'a12 la chaque année pour
son travail en tant que président des
états unis
quatre cent mille dollars il fait
donation à l'état et quand il s'agit de
ses affaires il les gère comme homme
d'affaires il fait l'optimisation
fiscale
tout le monde essaie de faire croire et
penser qu'il s'agit ici il s'agit de
transactions illégales
ce n'est pas légal c'est l'optimisation
fiscale toutes les personnes dans sa
position le fond que ce soit des
démocrates et de républicains
donc il faut pas faire ce qui est c'est
quelque chose de nouveau et c'est en
tout cas c'est la gestion de son
pratiquement et il a généré des milliers
d'emplois pour des gens qui travaillent
dans tous ces entreprises c'est ça ce
qui compte
et ça il va faire pour l'amérique il va
continuer à le faire et pas les
questions de vieux
lens je pense que contrairement à ce que
notre invité a auparavant indiqué je
pense qu'elle a la position et la
politique des démocrates ne rien dire
resté muet sur des questions de violence
pendant toute la convention démocratique
ils n'ont pas dit un mot sur toutes les
personnes qui ont été tuées des
policiers des américains ineson toutes
les meubles brûlés des centaines de
milliards de dollars en assurance qui ça
va coûter notre pays et ça continue je
dire qu'ils ont le contrôle des rues et
des villes aujourd'hui les démocrates
il n'aime pas les dia mais c'est bien
connu et doit aussi on vient entendre
donc grandi elle ose défendre le bilan
de donald trump
aujourd'hui ça va être aussi ça ce soir
ça à sa stratégie parce que on entendait
qu'il n'avait pas réellement de
programme à proposer contrairement aux
démocrates pour le débattement ça je
suis pas du tout d'accord avec vous
aussi vous voulez je pense que nous
sommes presque malgré-nous victime de
quatre ans de désinformation continue
des médias mainstream donald trump est
quelqu'un qui est arrivé en 2016 avec un
programme
il l'a mise en oeuvre c'est un programme
qu'on a qualifié de populiste au départ
qui est devenu progressivement un
programme conservateur en fait il a
réussi à relancer l'économie il a
renégocié les les accords de
libre-échange off pour qu'ils soient
plus favorables aux états unis il a fait
une des baisses fiscales les plus
impressionnantes de l'histoire des états
unis
et puis allez expliquer à des chrétiens
anti-avortement pro vie comme on dit aux
états unis que donald trump n'a pas de
programme c'est c'est le président qui a
le plus fait pour défendre leur cause
donc si vous voulez je crois que ce soir
il va jouer autre chose est ce que joe
biden va révéler involontairement qu'il
est faible qu'il est malade certains
disent même qu'ils essaient 1000 ou de
bien est ce que il va réussir à tenir le
choc
de quelle manière avec un certain humour
donald trump avant le avant l'élection a
demandé conteste by donne pour voir
s'ils étaient dopés alors évidemment le
new york times et le monde
d'autres prennent ça au premier degré et
en font des grands titres en 10 ans cet
homme est horrible mais la vérité c'est
que c'était un trait d'humour et que
c'était sa façon aussi de se détendre
avant un débat qui bien entendu est
important pour lui parce que baye
données faible buy donne et le pantin de
gens qui l'ont tous est là parce que il
n'arrivait pas à trouver un accord entre
bernie sanders l'ailé gauche du parti et
une aile droite plus raisonnable et donc
ils ont poussé by donne est en fait
byden n'a pas n'a pas véritablement les
moyens de gouverner s'il est si jamais
il était élu très vite on posera la
question de savoir si ce n'est pas sa
vice présidente qui gouverne
donc la question pour trump c'est de ne
pas être trop violent ce soir face à un
homme est bien évidemment affaibli et
pour autant de ne pas être non plus
dilettante en disant je suis déjà élu
parce que cet homme n'est pas capable de
gouverner les états unis alors juste
besoin de ces choses pour lui et je vous
proposais de réunions de voir l'un des
derniers sondages qui est sortie c'était
le 28 septembre de ville 20 regardez
alors voilà plus 6,4 points entre joe
biden une avance projob hayden on le
voit 49 25 % donald trump 43,1 % une
avance pour joe biden alors rendit à
lauzès que ce soir ça peut évoluer
est-ce que donald trump peut aller
chercher ses 7 points
ou alors effectivement ça va être
compliqué si on part du principe que ce
débat comme on nous l'expliqué
auparavant finalement ne va pas changer
grand chose
je serai ce je souhaite remettre les
sondages dans leur contexte
il faut rappeler n'est acquis en 2016
94% des sondages était erroné et qu'ils
aient dit que monsieur trompe allait
perdre les élections
aujourd'hui vous allez constater que
donc votre sondage avec laquelle je suis
pas d'accord vous avez constaté qu' en
baisse des trois ou quatre points
si vous regardez leur ancien sondages
yann baisse donc c'est les cours ont
aujourd'hui malgré que j'estime qu'ils
sont inexactes des chevaux sondages mais
les tendances générales dans tous les
sondages
messieurs bail de perdre du terrain
à partir de ce soir même les touts les
analystes indiquent qu'ils risquent de
perdre des millions et des millions de
votes si ils n'arrivent pas à bien
résister aux l'énergie des messieurs
trempe ce soir et edouard husson joe
biden a fait la tournée des états
industriels notamment pour reconquérir
l'électorat ouvrier blanc est ce que ce
soir les deux hommes vont s'adresser
justement à cet électorat edouard husson
alors là où vous avez raison c'est que
l'une des clés c'est bien sur
l'électorat que trump a courtisé en 2016
qui il a promis de ramener l'emploi de
ramener la confiance et la foi dans
l'avenir
lorsque vous dites que joe biden a fait
la tournée des états industriels vous
êtes assez indulgent pour lui il a fait
quelques sorties sporadiques et il n'a
pas véritablement labourer le terrain
comme donald trump le fait et continuent
à le faire
donald trump à 4 en deux mois il est en
bonne santé et il joue à plein de son
avantage cependant il est bien vrai que
il faut observer par exemple et là je
voudrais revenir sur la question des
sondages les sondages nationaux ne
veulent rien dire premièrement puisque
ça n'est pas une élection qui se joue à
la majorité nationale comme l'élection
président qu'elle pèse donc il faut
regarder état par état et si l'on
regarde est un par état il y à moins d'
avance pour by donne dans la plupart des
sondages qu' il n'y en avait pour
hillary clinton à la même époque
or hillary clinton a fini par perdre
donc il va falloir gaieté si évidemment
donald trump perdait le texas ça serait
extrêmement btan pour lui parce que ça
basculerait du mauvais côté s'ils
perdaient la floride
voilà c'est ça qu'il faut regarder et c
ce sont les résultats importants mais
vous savez il ya beaucoup d'électeurs à
cause de l'intimidation intellectuelle
des médias et du parti démocrate qui
n'osent pas avouer qu'ils vont voter
trempe
mais le jour du vin bas ils vont
effectivement léry électorale à cause du
vote par correspondance et là les
démocrates joue avec le feu parce
qu'effectivement il y aura
vraisemblablement des contestations il
est possible que l'on n'arrive pas à
proclamer le résultat dans la nuite
l'élection
parce qu'il y aura eu des risques de
fraude mais je voudrais vraiment en
profiter puisque vous me donnez
l'occasion pour dire l'information
concernant donald trump est totalement
asymétrique depuis quatre ans tout ce
qu'il pourra t on le dit et rien de ce
qu'il réussit des mises en valeur et
bien c'est bien entendu
edouard husson on vous donne le mot de
la fin
ayant dit randy yalouz est ce que ce
duel ce soir pour vous il a également
une importance mondiale selon vous moi
je pense que les cards sont surtout
importantes pour monsieur byden sait qu
il peut sortir énormément perdu
suite à ces duels ce soir et je crois
que monsieur tremblay il doit renforcer
sa position vis-à-vis de monsieur bailin
comme il a indiqué je crois que monsieur
byden c'est resté très très muet sur des
points importants il n'a peu sorti pour
faire de la compagne comme ils se
trompent pas c est que ce soit il va
faire face à son adversaire face aux
américains il va pas pouvoir faire des
petits discours de chez lui tout préparé
par ses équipes
il va être la plus naturelle face à face
sont aucune aide et c'est ça la vérité
le moment de vérité ce soir merci à tous
les deux d'avoir accepté notre
invitation merci à vous rendre diallo je
rappelle que cet avocat président de
république hanover 6 france merci à vous
edouard husson je rappelle que vous êtes
historien et c'est la fin de cette
émission on va se retrouver dans
quelques minutes pour 1 point complet
sur l'actualité a tout de suite sur rt
france
[Musique]
oui
qu'est ce qu'une entreprise sont des
entreprises que l'on maintient sous
perfusion combien sont-elles vous savez
plein d'entreprises aujourd'hui qui sont
des entreprises zombies et y en a plein
qui vont le devenir avec les mesures
qu'on est en train de prendre ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire dès le départ c'était
être capable d'analyser les plis dans
des entreprises pour savoir lesquels
souffrait simplement du confinement ou
de du ralentissement de l'activité il
est qu'elle était déjà en état de deux
morts avancé on est en train de tuer
l'économie et vous avez une façon de
relancer l'économie qui est beaucoup
plus saine que ce qui est annoncé là et
qui évite ce genre de problème c'est de
baisser les impôts de production
laissons les impôts sur les entreprises
qui marchent et donc qui font du
résultat celles qui sont déjà zombies
elles font pas de résultat donc vous
pouvez baisser les impôts vous n'allez
pas leur donner de l'argent en fait
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un en 42 résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie de catastrophe
ça veut dire à côté
cata strophe hague il ya un tournant
mais on re se remet à vivre mais dans
une autre direction c'est la première
fois dans l'histoire de l'humanité que
pour sauver des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais elle d'une décision
invraisemblable pour vous ça dépend
quelle valeur on attribue à la mort et à
la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie revient
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un départ
norales un débat éthique
[Musique]
le 14 juillet 2015 et signe à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président avait décidé de rompre
l'accord et d'imposer son régime de
sanctions au niveau international sur
1000 iran en grave difficulté au plan
économique et social pour la chine c'est
une très belle opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avaient ils un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en tous genres par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes ne les avons nous pas
pousser dans les bras d'un partenaire
qui va en profiter pour faire de l'iran
sa tête de pont au moyen orient
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire les bêtes des idées
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient des guignols
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême tous
les témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande île interview
[Musique]
le corps n'avait russa a une odeur c'est
pas l'odeur du virus que les chiens
cherche c'est l'odeur de ce que fait le
virus dans l'organisme c'est quoi toute
fiabilité du projet ne serait ce qu'au
business et on oscille entre 92 et 98 5%
ça fonctionne bien ça permet un d'être
rapide d'être non invasif et puis
d'avoir le résultat de façon instantanée
avec un coût qui est quand même bien
moindre plus que sur les coûts actuels
d'épaisseur on va pas sauver l'humanité
souffrent pour révolutionner les choses
avec le travail qu'on fait ou peut-être
faire en sorte qu fasse appel à savoir
faire qui est un savoir-faire médical
aussi dans un domaine un peu différent
qui est celui de l'animal mais après
tout l'homme c'est un animal complot
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
parlement qui vote de grands objectifs
massif à peu à la manière des plans
quinquennaux soviétique le soutien à
l'éolien c'est entre 70 et 90 milliards
d'euros
la facture d'électricité des français va
forcément monteil désormais ses financés
par les taxes qu'ils reportent sur le
carburant là les fameuses taxes
d'ailleurs qui ont provoqué la colère
des gilet jaune
en fait the holy pour faire de
l'écologie il est tombé assez difficile
d'expliquer aux gens que on laboure les
fonds marins ont détruit un écosystème
humain économique et tout ça pour le
bien de la planète
et y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend sa
fille est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens qui
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas de la louve
ligue parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est on
dirait qu'il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la france n'est pas le seul pays qui a
eu des colonies dans le monde mais c'est
le seul qui refuse d'avancer qu'ils
refusent de s'adapter à l'air du temps
d'accepter un partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec ses anciennes colonies et
je constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
dont aucune des colonies n'a jamais été
développé comment faire en fait pour
établir cette relation gagnant gagnant
c'est pour nous africains de porter à la
tête de nous et à des gens qui